also mentioned the word bi-directional
earlier and when i was learning about
this the way that i like to understand
this was that in computer science
generally computer scientists think and
can only think in terms of you have an
input then there's a black box and you
have an output and that's essentially
computer science in a nutshell it's a
bit more complicated than that but it's
in a nutshell it's do you have an input
you perform some calculation and you get
an output the reason why you said
bi-directional at least the way that i
understand it so please correct this is
it's because of actions in that model
where there's input black box output
that's generally if we want to use the
term embody cognition more on the
cognition side so you're just this black
box where you're impressed with sensory
information the input is your senses
you're sensing all of what's happening
and then this output now
is the actions that generally a computer
sits there but we're creatures in this
world at least we think we're creatures
in a physical world the black box has a
model and then one way of maximizing or
showing that your model is correct is by
updating your model or it's by changing
what you've sensed in order to match the
model now to change what you've sensed
is to act so it's useful to think of two
black boxes so there's one that's
inputting to the other and then the
output goes into the other which is the
external this is the internal this is
the cell it senses and then it acts upon
the world and then that changes the
world which then changes what you sense
so is that the reason that you said
bi-directional
yeah no no i think that's a really
important observation yeah so you know
before we were talking about these
states that separate the inside from the
outside and i made a big thing that they
had comprised sensory and active states
and that there is a
a two-way traffic here and that two-way
traffic instantiates exactly what you're
talking about which is a circular
causality
so you know i use the word
self-evidencing and described it as
soliciting evidence for
sensory data
that it provides evidence for your model
of what's going on but in soliciting
this is something that a computer would
not normally do a passive or sessile
artifact like a computer it would not be
in charge of nor would it terribly worry
or indeed be equipped with the capacity
to select the inputs to select the data
they had to analyze so just having a
statistical package you give it some
data and it produces an outcome you know
say a p value or some kind of inference
so a lot of computing and a lot of
machine learning you give it data and it
provides a prediction or a
classification
that's not the kind of computational
process that is implied by the free
energy principle it's much more as you
put it um inactive it has you know the
aspirations to provide a mathematical
image of the action perception cycle
where crucially
you have to go and decide what data
to base your inferences on by
acting upon the world
so
that um that sort of inactive aspect is
the thing that distinguishes this kind
of formalism this calculus is bayesian
calculus which is quintessentially
inactive you know it's not just a
you know a good computer it can be made
a good computer just by removing active
states if you want to um but that
you know that would be a limiting and a
rather um
biophysically unrealizable and
unsustainable kind of artifact uh you
know
the whole point here is that there is a
reciprocal exchange in the world so your
notion of having two black boxes talking
to each other i think a really nice
notion
and indeed
when
applying
this principle of least action the free
energy principle
to interesting scenarios um one ends up
very often um putting two um
sets of uh internal states each equipped
with markov blankets talking to each
other so the active states of one
blanket
or one particle or one person now
constitute the sensory states of the
other and vice versa so you've got now
two systems trying to model each other
and if their game is to effectively
provide or solicit the most evidence
for their model of the rest of the world
which is just another
artifact very much like you who's doing
trying to do exactly the same thing
what you are you what will inevitably
emerge
from that joint minimization or free
energy or the maximization of marginal
likelihood is the kind of active
engagement that renders say you and me
as the two black boxes
renders us mutually predictable so what
we will do is we will come to share the
same generative model the same narrative
so that i can predict exactly what
you're going to say next
given that's the kind of thing that i
would say because that's the sort of
world that i'm trying to model so
immediately you have this um
picture
of the minimization of the joint uh
variational free energy or the um
the the maximization of the joint
marginal likelihood for shared models
and one gets from that sort of quite
compelling and interesting
um
formulations and multi-agent games
communication
synchronization between
conspecifics
that all rest upon
trying to resolve uncertainty
in the service of securing actively
enlisting asking questions of the other
black box you asking me questions me
asking you questions
just so i can understand what's going on
out there where you are going on out
there